this week was a great lesson how nice to
estimate it's Monday today my guests
come working from home is great and
having a separate office in your home
and bigger person who works remotely
it's really really awesome for me but
when the family comes and you are a bit
out of your daily routine it's getting
harder I was just doing the fix for our
selectable text in my family o'clock and
these small changes make make you users
not the app they make the users feel
that you really care about them let's
week somebody wrote under the video
about silent game that they don't go to
spot a mile to check in the project that
they are not a private I think that if
you really devote your time to start any
project it's better to do it in a one
hundred twenty percent because it's
still your portfolio study you devote
your time and time is the the most
precious Cara see soon that you have the
journey of the week was like that so
who's the time spent with my
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is the best motivational tool so
whenever you are not in the mood for
coding whenever you are not focused
enough to start cooking because you are
tired or you are thinking about
something else they're not in the music
that you like and start coding it works
[Music]
the first photo sauce is that it's very
organized very modular and very useful
and assign natural step after getting to
know CSS and using it for a while the
coding says seems to be really easier to
maintain and easier to add another
component easier to come back after time
to and great for bigger apps great for
working a team great for maintenance of
the project and coming back to it later
because of its importance because of its
variables and the huge plus is also how
you write themselves how pin it is that
you don't need this Xbox any comments
that you don't need this extra rockets
that's why I pay with people call sauce
well this scss okay they are convertible
you can you know change one into honor
but see SS is not as a as s
[Music]
[Music]
I really admire you the guys who whacked
on a daily basis and come back after
work and start learning to code very
often as I wrap people did as a second
job they do it at night so I really
really admire you and I keep the fingers
crossed for your success because it's
really hard and I haven't just only get
and it's harder to stay on a daily track
of learning to code I'm focused on
holding the whole thing and majority of
the time I spend on coping or learning
to code on learning to design but you
guys really do it you know partially
afterwards and still manage to do it
successfully you wrong guys so it's
really something awesome and this needs
that power inside
[Music]
its first day I just finish writing the
first draft of my new multiple or medium
seven minutes to read it so it's perfect
timing coming back to it tomorrow this
week because of the project that I also
start soon I was comparing that to
typing tools that I've using before but
not a long time so I had to revise them
once again and I decided on experience
design when I do the designs for myself
very often I do not use them at all
because sketching gets very often enough
majority of prototyping tools are really
similar so if you know one it's easy to
use the other one what's different super
the backing to is very often the price
and the level of functionality if it's
really mad major product or not
this week I gathered q brownie points so
together I have right now 464 brand new
points and and I was active but not as I
wanted and but still the for the first
four days I was active also Peter
helping others so from monday to
thursday i gathered few more homes to my
500 round challenge the article is ready
right now to be revised by quincy and i
want to publish it an integral x
application and when we talk about this
article I was focusing on how much did
it cost me to harm this funding
certificate and I focus mostly on data
on numbers and later discuss details and
man she knew sources so feedback and to
think about sharing and came back and
also what's next so let's show you the
whole story right now I hope you will
read it later
I will find you the link once it's
published the way I'm writing articles
and it's always planning it and later
writing the first block and coming back
to it after one day something's coming
to it and after longer break if I have
time and polishing it so changing what's
needed also expected things happen when
it comes to the projects because all of
a sudden last week on Friday Freda
clients contacted me about the products
I go to two calls this week about new
projects which you have to connect with
extra time needed for that when you
connect it with in for having hotel at
home and working remotely from the same
home and adding these extra hours as a
result at the end of the week you think
I dinner a lot I didn't learn a lot of
new stuff and so your motivation fall
down and the problem is that it's not
the end like that one week like that
that I have to start us on the project
and come back to the routine decision
taking and replacing what you need to do
fast in this situation where your time
is shrinking and a lot of unexpected
things with gas happen this 13 this week
also how to manage my time better how I
manage my planning better and so for
sure in the last level do my best to use
what I've learned this week not to make
the same mistakes keep on going and plan
wisely and see you next week learning
about sex box
[Music]